こんにちははじめしゃちょーです！
東京なうなんですけども、
東京のドンキで変な商品を見つけました！
へっ、これ....
はい！
ぜーんぶすっ太郎
ジョーーーボボボボボボボッッ!!
これがすっ太郎ですね。
こんな感じです
すっ太郎くんの顔が描いてあります
つまんで、もどすと、ぜ〜〜んぶすいこむ！
なん、なんでこんなの作ったんだろうな
全く意味が分からないです
あそびかた
とりあえず、なんか、ねばねば液が付いてて、
それをこのすっ太郎が全部、吸ってくれる
っていうおもちゃらしいです
１ついいですか。
本当に意味が分からない
なんで、作ったんだろう
てか、どういう遊び方があるか
全然分からないんですけど
とりあえず、ちょっと気になりすぎて
買ってしまいました！！
開けていきます
あっ、出ました
この子は、すっ太郎くんです
で、これがねばねば液かな
もうぱっと見、スライムでしかないんですけど
開けてみましょう
えっ、もうスライムでしかないっすよ、これ
うぁあ！、これをすっ太郎が
すいこんでらしいですね
じゃあ、すっ太郎くん、
吸ってみましょう
いきますっ
え、どうやってやんの、これ？！
すっ太郎くんをつけて、
ほっぺたをグーーっ
ぅうう、わぁ、汚なっ
おいおいおい、
ほっぺたをグニュってやって、戻すと......
なんでだ、なんでだ？！
こうやって、口をつけて....
....ねぇ笑
なんだろう、これ
全然、吸ってくれないんですけど
おぉ〜
ねぇえ笑
それ、なんかさ、ちょっとさ、
はい、というわけで、ちょっと
多少は吸ってくれるみたいなんですけど
全く意味が分からん！
ねぇ、わぁ、きもっ
なるほど、本当はこれで全部、
吸って欲しいみたいな感じだな、多分
分かるよ、吸ったらお前のしたいことが
こういうことだろ
多分、これだよ、こうやって....
押し込むと......
ねぇ、吸う気ある？！
吐かないのっ！
コツの問題かな...なんかコツがあるのかな....
ほらなんかね、
いつも惜しいところまで行けるんすけど...
この先が行けない...
ちょ、全部吸ってみよ、とりあえず一回
おぉおおお！
おっおっお〜
すっ太郎がついに、全部吸えました！
おいっ！、はい、というわけで、
無事、吸えました
なんかうまいこと調整出来れば、
すっ太郎はなんでも吸ってくれるみたいですね
すっ太郎ですね、
多分、なんでも吸える気がします、コイツ
俺も吸ってくれんのかな....
くさっ！！！
え、なんか、液体に近いものだったら、
なんでも吸えるんじゃないかと
思って、ちょっといろいろ準備してみました
ちょっと吸わせてみましょう
まずは、ローション！
実際、吸える可能性はあるんだよな.....
ちょっと、ローションやってみます
よし、こん〜だけのローションを吸えたら、
もうお前、大したもんだよ
よし、では吸ってみます！
行くぞ！
GO!!!
お〜、吸えてる、吸えてる
吸えますね
ちゃんと、ローション吸えます
ね、泡吹かない！
というわけで、すっ太郎は
ローションは吸えるんですけど、
泡を吹いてしまいます
お茶目ですねっ！
続いて、洗顔クリーム行ってみましょう
洗顔クリームもね、なんかね、
絶妙に硬いような部分があるんで
これが吸えるか吸えないかは
結構、大きなポイントにはなると思います
じゃあ、行ってみます
いけすっ太郎！
洗顔クリームを吸うんや！
おっ
おーー
ファッ!?
すっ太郎おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお！！！